there's a life cycle
right
your teens your 20s your 30s and so on
and every phase is a little bit
different or quite a bit different and
people have asked me uh in their 20s
what is good advice for their 20s you
are about to go independent you were
dependent on others and now others are
going to become dependent on you and
you're going to work and you're going to
learn and you're going to try to be
successful this whole different phase in
your life the best thing I can say is
make your work and your passion the same
thing and don't forget about the money
part okay now you're in a different
phase of your life you're in the phase
of your life that your job is getting
more serious your responsibilities are
going to get more serious perhaps your
relationships are going to get more
serious this is a stage of your life
where you might be choosing a partner
and you may be having children and as
you're choosing a partner and having
children you're going to deal with the
work life balance issue and so the bit
of advice that I want to convey at that
is that you can look at that
um on us all I have to choose between
giving up my work hours and I have to
choose to have a quality of life you
have to choose less if you know how to
get more of an out of an hour you can
have more life in life and so that there
are things that you can do in my book
principles I wrote some of those things
down that you can be more efficient more
effective and you can get more out of
life so the trade-off is less okay what
would I recommend first of all
I recommend for every phase of your life
meditation if you can meditate and you
have the calmness and the Equanimity to
look at that I think that that's an
important thing and then I think also
that if you think about the
relationships that you're in that then
may be more strained
to differentiate those relationships who
are the people that you want to be
around and how do you work with them to
get you through those issues